this segment is probably the most
critical one for the purpose of
understanding what the Poisson process
really is and how it behaves there will
be almost no mathematical formulas but
the segment will be quite dense in terms
of conceptual reasoning so pay a lot of
attention in a nutshell we will argue
that the Poisson process has
memorylessness properties that are
entirely similar to those that we have
seen for the Bernoulli process this
should not be surprising since the
Poisson process can be thought of as a
limiting case of the Bernoulli process
we will reason through these properties
not in the style of a formal
mathematical proof but with an intuitive
argument but I would like to assure you
that the intuitive argument can be
translated into a rigorous proof the
first property is the following the
process starts at time 0 you come in and
start watching at let's say time 7 or
more generally instead of time 7 suppose
that you come in and start watching at
some time little T the important thing
here is that little T is a constant
it's a deterministic number starting at
that time what will you see well the
original process was Poisson this means
that disjoint intervals in the original
process are independent therefore
disjoint intervals in the process that
you will be seeing will also be
independent furthermore during any
little interval of length Delta in the
process that you see we still have
probability lambda times Delta
approximately of seeing an arrival
therefore what you see also satisfies
the properties of a Poisson process and
is itself a Poisson process second the
original process was Poisson so
different intervals are independent so
whatever happens in this interval is
independent from whatever happens
that interval but that interval
corresponds to the future of the process
and therefore the future of the process
what you get to see is independent from
the past history and so the conclusion
is that the process that you get to see
is a Poisson process which is
independent of the history until that
the time that you started watching and
we say therefore that what you see is a
fresh starting process the Poisson
process starts fresh at time T we have
the fresh start property and similar to
the language we use for the Bernoulli
process the fresh start property means
that you see a process that's
independent of the past and which has
the same statistical properties as if
this was time zero as if the process was
just starting right now one consequence
of this fresh start property is the
following you start watching at time T
and you're interested in the time it
takes until the next arrival what are
the properties of this random variable
well since you have a fresh starting
Poisson process at this time this is the
time until the first arrival in this
fresh starting Poisson process and the
time until the first arrival in a
process that is just starting we know
that it has an exponential distribution
so this is going to be an exponential
random variable with the same parameter
lambda furthermore because the process
starts fresh whatever happens in that
future is independent from the past and
so this random variable the remaining
time is independent of whatever happened
in the past until time T
now let us look at a sound quite a
different situation you start watching
the process at time T one time T one is
the time of the first arrival and you
start watching from here on what is it
that you're going to see suppose that
the first arrival happened let's say at
time equal to three so we're
conditioning on this event in that case
you start watching the process at time
three and you also know that the first
arrival happened at time three but this
fact about the first arrival happening
at time three belongs to the history of
the process until time three this is
information about the past and does not
affect what is going to happen after
time three the process after time three
will be independent from the history
until time three and whatever happens
until that time so starting at that
particular time three what you see is a
Poisson process that is independent from
the past now this argument is valid even
if I were to use here a three point five
or three point four or three point seven
no matter when this first arrival
occurred what I see starting from this
time is a Poisson process which is
independent from the past at the time of
the first arrival the process just
starts fresh as a consequence of this
and by repeating the argument that we
carried out for the remaining time until
the next arrival up here we can repeat
this argument and argue that the time
until the next arrival in this fresh
starting process this will also be an
exponential random variable now this
time until the next arrival is the
difference between the second arrival
time and the first arrival time and we
denote it by t2 what we just argued is
that this time until the next arrival
is going to be an exponential random
variable and also it is independent from
the past and in particular it is
independent from t1 so the time until
the second arrival starting from the
first arrival the second inter arrival
time is a random variable that has an
exponential distribution that is the
same distribution as that of t1 and is
independent from t1 now we can extend
this argument and look at the case inter
arrival time for example if the arrival
numbered K minus 1 occurred here and the
K arrival occurs here this difference
here we denote it by TK and by arguing
in a similar way that the process starts
fresh at this particular time the time
until the next arrival will also be an
exponential random variable with the
same distribution and furthermore will
be independent from the past history and
therefore independent from the earlier
inter arrival times and this has lots of
important implications for example the
time until the K arrival which is the
sum of the first K inter arrival times
is the sum of independent identically
distributed exponential random variables
in particular this means that we can
find the PDF of YJ by convolving
the exponential PDF of these inter
arrival times convolving this
exponential PDF with itself J times and
this is indeed one way to find the PDF
of YK but fortunately for us we were
able to find it with a much simpler
argument and we already know what it is
but this property here is also useful
for finding the mean and the variance of
YK the mean of the sum is the sum of the
means and since the random variables are
independent the variance of the sum is
the sum of the variances we know what is
the mean and the variance
an exponential and so by multiplying
that by K we obtain the mean of the K
arrival time and the variance of the
case arrival time and so we now know the
mean and variance of the Erlang PDF of
order K a second implication of this
property is more theoretical more
conceptual recall that we defined the
Poisson process in terms of an
independence assumption and an
assumption on the probability of
arrivals during a small interval but we
could have defined the Poisson process
as follows consider a sequence of
independent identically distributed
Exponential's call them TK and use these
to define the arrival times this is a
way of constructing a process what we
argued in this segment is that a Poisson
process under the original definition
satisfies this new definition one can
complete the argument to show that the
two definitions are equivalent it is
possible to argue that if we define an
arrival process in this manner this
arrival process will also satisfy the
basic properties of the Poisson process
this argument can indeed be carried out
but we will not go through it a final
implication which is a little more
practical if you want to simulate the
Poisson process how would you do it
given what we now know the most natural
way is the following we generate
independent identically distributed
exponential random variables using for
example a random number generator and
then use these exponential random
variables to construct the values of the
inter arrival times and this way
construct the complete time history of
the Poisson process